just like titles in a Bookshop are
divided into fiction and non-fiction we
can communicate along a spectrum ranging
from colorful storytelling to stating
plain facts
when fiction and non-fiction speak to us
they serve opposing purposes to
understand this difference let's examine
the definition and then a famous example
of a classic tragedy
[Music]
the tragedy is a type of dramatic work
in which the main character experiences
a downfall due to circumstances that are
beyond their control traditionally the
intention of tragedy is to invoke an
accompanying catharsis a pain that
awakens pleasure now the fiction
once upon a time a boy was born to the
king and queen of Thebes the boy's name
was Oedipus soon after his birth a
prophet warned the king that the boy
would grow up to kill his father and to
marry his mother to avoid this
catastrophe the king ordered one of his
servants to kill the baby but the
servant couldn't do it and left the
innocent child with a shepherd
the shepherd brought the boy to the king
of Corinth who raised him as his own
when Oedipus grew to be a man a prophet
told him his Destiny not knowing that he
had been adopted Oedipus left Corinth to
run away from his Misfortune on his way
to Thebes he met an old man with his
servants
the two got into a fight and Oedipus
killed them all when Oedipus arrived in
Thebes he encountered the evil Sphinx
that Menace the city after Oedipus
solved the Sphinx's riddle it killed
itself to celebrate this Victory Oedipus
was named the new King of Thieves and
given the current queen as his bride for
the former King had mysteriously been
killed
years later after they had four children
plagues began to destroy the city
Oedipus tried to find out the reason for
this Misfortune when he heard rumors
that Thebes would be doomed until the
day that the murderer of the former King
was punished Oedipus first tried to find
the villain and then began to understand
what had actually happened
when he realized that he had killed his
father and made love to his mother he
blinded himself as he could not bear to
see the children he had fathered
now what do you think about the two
examples and how do the two help you
understand a tragedy
the story appears real and feels alive
you can experience it sense it
emotionally see it with your imagination
and because this can be exciting it is
recorded in your brain changes your mind
and will be remembered for a long time
but there is a downside
[Music]
stories are so powerful you may start to
think that they are more common than
they are and you become biased this
effect is also known as the law of small
numbers which is why we also need fights
[Music]
facts are abstract and boring reading
non-fiction is not exciting and is hence
not easily recorded in your memory
in fact a mere month after reading an
entire book most of us remember not more
than one single idea and because facts
are weak and they compete for attention
with stories that are powerful they
hardly ever change your mind however
there is one thing they do well
non-fiction provides our mind a theory a
heuristic and a framework that allows us
to make assumptions and generalize
[Music]
put them on a spectrum and you'll find
high retention versus low retention easy
reading versus hard studying and a
subjective perspective versus
objectivity
for the polarizing nature smart
Educators often combine the two just as
the quote goes when one man dies it's a
tragedy and when a million die it's
statistics to better understand the true
nature of War we need to consider both
what do you think what will you learn
from this video possibly a good mix of
Both Worlds share your thoughts and your
favorite way to grasp complex topics in
the comments below
[Music]
if you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation you
can support us visit patreon.com Sprouts
just visit us learn how it works and
what's in it for you we hope to see you
there
and if you are a parent or educator
check out our website
sproutschools.com there you can find
this and other video lessons additional
resources and classroom activities
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com